ん
ムース
だああああ
ん
200分
持った
ん
ポッ
うん
た
エイ
muta
[音楽]
先生前集まりました
一体何なんですか探偵さんこんなところに人を集めて
今回皆さんにお集まりいただいたのは他でもありませんこっちは忙しいんだよ
配布してくれ足も仕事で車の修理をしてただけなんですよ
早く次に行かせてください落ち着いてください
うーん
実は先ほど
この言える殺人事件がありました
[音楽]
疑っているのかは歌が強いください教えてください
うんはをついては落ち着いていっ
今回の事件の被害者は3段のバラ洋平さん
32車
職業はユーチューバーで間違いないです
はい間違いありません
現在は長期の休暇を取っているため3日前からしばらく在宅しています
言い間違いありません
あなた長
私のご
3段の蔵様のお家で家事を担当しております
i 大和ハイカーと申します
なるほど
確かハイカーさん
あなた主体の第一発見者として死体を発見したのはいつごろでしたか
私女な記憶が正しければ確か
お昼の12時頃だったと思います
台所でお料理をしておりまして叫び声が聞こえたなぁと思って
旦那様の様子を伺い切ったと思っ
9分えったんなさ通して何でうっっ
goo トゥディ
aname
me 2
えっ
うっ
どうせお前がやったんだろう日頃の恨みとかで
ea 私たちが3段ノールさんはプロスルーなんてありませんぐるせ早くは駆除しろや
付けるのはまだ早い
[音楽]
第一打犬舎の相川さんあなたが最初に死体を見ていた時にいきっていたものを
覚えていますかね
ハイカーさん
あなたが渡すとで行った時
あなたの手には包丁が握られていたあー
俺見ろやっぱりお前らが犯人じゃわたしは仕事に戻らせてもらうよ
います
家
まあが彼が犯人という確証はありません
あー殺害の方法に関しては不明ですが犯行現場の近くにはつまみれの放送がなぜか2つ
をつけました
2つ他に怪しいものがなかったため
おそらくシーンは
視察でほぼ確定だと思いますちょっと待てよ通して二つの包丁が一つは分かりませんが
もう一つの包丁は
相川さん
あなたはですよねー
ちょっと方約3あなたの定位
血の跡がなんじゃこりゃー葉山さん
あなた事件の直前何していらっしゃいました私はただこの
新米の範囲母の料理を見てただけなんですこのて後はきっと
ハイカーがついつい間違えて私をさせてしまってその時に出血しちゃうと思う
me んじゃ
今日は料理中にハイカーがついつい間違えて私をさせてしまって
その時に出血し措置ですこれが先ほど配管嫌いだけがです
動い1じゃないか早く病院に行きなさい片方の訪中も家は葉山さんの家ということです
ね
ということは
もう1本の包丁が半身
そう
つまり犯人は
この外犬